I'm going to start by getting the portfolio working because I kind of want to
see some pictures already. It looks like I need to finish up the
addFinishedWork method, alright. Now, I need to actually create that
FinishedPhoto class. So, I'll come back to my overview and make a new class
FinishedPhoto. I'll move this down here since it's going to be used by the
portfolio. Now, basically I just want the FinishedPhoto to have the location of
the file and the name of the photographer. So, I'll create instance variables
for them, initialize them in the constructor and make it possible for the
portfolio to get the information back out later. Now, I can go back to the
portfolio and compile again, and if I were to actually use the correct class
names, I now have the collecting of finished works working. To display them,
I'll have to fill in the bits that I left out before. I'll make the picture
based on what's saved in my finished work object. Translate it to the correct
position and draw it. The signature will have the same x coordinate. Whoops,
looks like I have a bit of a name collision here. I've called the picture
object photo. And I've also called the finishedPhoto, photo. So I'm going to
call this one work. And I'll need to be careful to change it in exactly the
right places. And now I can actually get the height of the Picture object, so
that I'll know where to place the text. And I'll get the actual text for the
signature from the work object not the picture object. Let's see how we were
doing. I should probably actually call the constructor when I'm making a Text
object. And now it's better. So let's see how this is working. I'll go back to
the overview and create a class PortfolioDemo. PortfolioDemo will have a main
method where I'll create a Portfolio object and then add some finished work to
it. Here's one of the images I know is in the package. And I'm actually
going to use the original photographer's name here. And I'll add two more. And
at the end, I'll want to display the work. Looks like I should capitalize
correctly. Try this again. Now, if I run my PortfolioDemo, it prints out the
three photos with the names just as I wanted. Looks like I'm ready to start
using the portfolio in the Photographer class. The photographer will need to
able to accept assignments. When a photographer accepts an assignment, they'll
take a photo, which in this simulation will mean finding a file name based on a
description for the assignment. Then the photographer will add the finished
work and their name into the portfolio. There are a few ways that we could get
a hold of the portfolio. One is that we could just have it passed in as a
parameter. In this case, I'll just put it in as an instance variable. Either
one works. But I'm going to need to take it in as a parameter in the
constructor. And I'm also going to need the name of the photographer. Which
will also come in as a parameter in the constructor. Now, that should be all
set. But my photographer's probably not working all that well yet. I keep using
assignments. But assignments haven't been defined yet. So I'll make a new
class. This is all getting pretty squished. That's a bit better. Now, the
Assignment class isn't going to have a whole lot in it. Basically, the
Assignment object is what's going to be stored in the to do list for the
manager and then used by the photographer to know what assignment they should
do. I know that I'll need a description for the photographer, and I'll
eventually need a priority but I'll come back to that. And here's my get a
method for the description. Now, the photographer should compile. Once I fix
the typos in the assignment and now I can write a PhotographerDemo that shows
that the Photographer class works. I'll make a new Photographer And give the
Photographer portfolio. I'll fix a little typo, take out the s that I had here
in the Photographer class. And then I'll make sure that all of the assignments
made it into the portfolio by displaying the finished work. When I run the
PhotographerDemo, I'll get three photos with me pretending to have taken them.
So that's looking pretty good. Now, I only need to fix the Manager class though
the Manager does have some of the most complicated logic. The most interesting
part is when we give out the assignments. The Manager will need a list of
unfinished assignments. I already defined that earlier in one of the hint
videos along with a list of photographers. Now, there's this detail about
assigning the photographer who was hired first the highest priority assignment.
So, it looks like I'll be iterating over all of the photographers. And I'm
going to want to look at the one who was hired first, first. Luckily, this
won't be too difficult since I'm storing all the photographers in an array
list. They're going to be stored in the list in the order that I hired them. So
if I iterate over the list, I'm going to iterate over the photographers,
starting with the one that was hired first. Now, for trickier part. I'll
want to find the highest priority assignment but you already mostly know how to
do this. So I'll quickly make a helper method that does this. Now, there is one
hiccup here, I'll need to add the getPriority method to the Assignment class.
But that wasn't especially complicated and now I'm back. Looks like I tried to
index into an array list using parentheses. Alright, now I'm using the get
method and correcting spelling errors. And I should be able to use my
getHighestPriorityAssignment method. So, for each photographer, I'll get the
highest priority assignment, give it to a photographer and remove it so I don't
do it twice. And one more gotcha. I only want to do these things if there's
actually another assignment to be done. So, if there are no assignments in the
list of assignments, I'll skip all of this. I can add an else return here and
the moment I realize there are no more assignments, I would stop looking
through the photographers. This isn't necessary but it might skip a lot of
steps if our company gets really, really big and we have thousands of
photographers. I think I'm done with the giveOutAssignments method. Now, I'll
make sure I've implemented all the other methods. I'll need to add a
photographer to the list when I hire a photographer and make sure to initialize
all of my array lists, as well as a new portfolio. When I get a new assignment,
I'll need to add the new assignment to the list of assignments to be done. And
at the end when I'm ready to check the portfolio, I'll use the portfolio to
display the finished work. Did it work? Looks like it. If you stuck with that
problem all the way through and got it, great job. And if you didn't hope that
you learned something by seeing me go through the exercise. Now, that I have
this working I would probably want to go back and clean up all of the
documentation. But I wont make you spend any more time on this example. Ky has
some important concepts to show you with car share program.